tens of thousands of people still don't
have power for a fourth straight day in
Moore County North Carolina as officials
investigate Saturday's gunfire attack on
electrical substations the local utility
says everyone should have their lights
on by tonight
and despite the ordeal Mark Strassman
reports the communities are coming
together in the Darkness
Moore County North Carolina had to act
fast we feed about 400 a day for lunch
at Aberdeen Elementary Antoinette Ross
and Derek marks removed box after box of
food at risk of spoiling how much longer
does this food have before it would go
bad well they said 72 hours
they give it 72 hours been out since
Saturday night about eight o'clock
the food shuttled to a warehouse with
functioning freezers just in time one of
many ways this community has dealt with
a power crisis caused by a deliberate
gun attack that disabled two of its
substations
more than 750 people received free food
and water from the North Carolina food
bank this is very helpful investigators
have yet to identify suspects or learn
why the stations were attacked our
investigation continues at a very fast
pace according to the Department of
energy there were at least 70 reported
incidents involving intentional attacks
to the U.S power grid this year CBS News
obtained a federal law enforcement
bulletin that says Oregon and Washington
State experienced physical attacks on
substations using hand tools arson
firearms and metal chains possibly in
response to an online call for a tax on
critical infrastructure and whoever the
perpetrator is
I can assure you I hope they turn the
power off in the sale they put you in
here's the good news for the thousands
of people here who've been living in a
cold house Gail all of them should have
power Again by midnight tonight
all right that's good news they need it
right now thank you Mark it's a long
time to go without heat thanks